eighth grade was directed by Bo Burnham
and stars Elsie Fisher as young Kayla a
girl in her last week of eighth grade
trying to survive because it's
absolutely terrible and her life is
painfully embarrassing and this is
something that I think a lot of kids and
adults can relate to if they've ever
been that shy kid in class or the
unpopular kid trying to reach out trying
to make friends but it takes a different
approach to it than films you may have
seen like this from the 90s or early
2000s and so much of this film relies on
our hero young Kayla and Elsie Fisher
gives a star-making performance here
she's totally charming completely real
and I basically loved everything that
she brought to this movie I thought she
was so fantastic and the writing was
also very realistic and very authentic
for eighth graders the film bridges the
gap between acts by having her make a
YouTube video and we see a YouTube video
in which she's talking about how to gain
confidence or something like that and
then we see her dialogue overlaid over a
sequence in which we witness her trying
to do something that she's talking about
in her YouTube videos and what I loved
about that is that through those videos
that she's making she's trying to reach
out she's trying to connect we never
really get an idea of if anyone's
actually watching her channel that much
except for one person in the film who
mentions it but despite wanting to
create videos about things like
confidence or how to be yourself she has
a really hard time doing that in real
life which I thought was an excellent
commentary on modern-day social media
I'm not sure if that's what Bo Burnham
was going for but it does feel like he's
saying look at all these people who are
online telling us how to act or how to
feel but in everyday life they have no
idea how to do it
and I thought that was really beautiful
and the film captured it extremely well
throughout the movie Kayla would get
opportunities to do things she wanted to
do maybe she got invited to a party or
maybe she got to go out with some people
a little bit older than her and that
excited her every single time something
was looking up for her in the back of my
mind I'm thinking no it's about to crash
and burn this is so terrible I'm getting
anxiety just watching this terrible
flashbacks of eighth grade oh my god and
that's why the writing is so good
because you always feel like the Hammers
about to drop on this poor girl you
never really feel like she's crawling
out of this introverted and very
embarrassing phase that she's in even
when things are kind of looking up for
her
her father portrayed by Josh Hamilton in
the film I thought was wonderful he has
some beautiful scenes with her however
his character does sometimes feel almost
too good to be true like so much of the
film feels very grounded and then he's
just the best dad ever you could
possibly have ever and it just it just
felt a little bit fantastical to me but
it wasn't something that took me out of
the film it was just kind of in
retrospect looking back on how authentic
everything else was he did feel sort of
like impossibly perfect and the film
does follow a formula that we're used to
seeing in films like this for instance
there's a young boy that she has a major
crush on every time she sees him we get
a close-up of his eyes and some booming
techno music which I thought was
absolutely hilarious but there's also
that one kid who's really nice to her
and in your head you're like yeah that's
the person you should be talking to you
not this guy and we've seen that many
times in films before - but it's the
wonderful writing the sharp comedy and
the commentary on today's youth that
continue to make this film extremely
entertaining it also has a
nerve-wracking scene in a car I saw this
film with two of my friends and I think
we just held our breath for like five
straight minutes it was incredible
extremely well done the film is
definitely worth seeing it has great
performances I really enjoyed eighth
grade and I'm gonna give it an A - guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
but I do also want to give a major thank
you to David Gregory of Severn films for
sending me an early copy of The
Changeling
the 1980 horror film with George C Scott
that I find very overlooked this is
gonna be officially released on August
7th you can pre-order it now this isn't
sponsored they did not ask me to do this
I'm doing this purely because they sent
this to me and I think it's a wonderful
horror film that not a lot of people
talk about as much as I think they
should I think it's extremely extremely
well shot and
we acted it's one of my favorite haunted
house movies and now that it's finally
getting an HD re-release I'm excited to
pop it in and watch it because I've
always had my old DVD with shaky like
you can see the film like processing
through it almost it's just it's it's
such a terrible transfer but this I
can't wait to see what it looks like
please do check out that film if you get
a chance and once again thank you so
much to David Gregory from Severin films
for sending me that early release guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and look forward to more reviews very
soon and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you